teens are experiencing a mental health
crisis according to a new CDC survey on
the well-being of young people 42
percent of high school students reported
feeling persistent sadness or
hopelessness in the latest data and
thoughts of suicide are rising with 24
percent of girls reporting that they
made a plan to end their lives in our
new book out today the emotional lives
of teenagers raising connected capable
and compassionate adolescents
psychologist Lisa D'Amour offers coping
mechanisms she says intense emotions
like anxiety can be an opportunity
instead of an obstacle Lisa good morning
how you doing good morning I'm good all
right so why is team mental health in
Decline
well in the decade before the pandemic
we were seeing Rising rates of anxiety
and depression and then of course the
pandemic did not help
so we are now dealing with the aftermath
of that and teens worry about things
like climate change they worry about
political polarization there's a lot of
stress on being a teenager
but one of the challenges we're also
facing is how we're talking about what
mental health is the way the culture
talks about it has moved to a place that
doesn't line up with how we understand
it in Psychology so often when people
talk about mental health they seem to
suggest that you know you're mentally
healthy if you feel good or calm or
relaxed but that's not our view in
Psychology for us mental health is two
things it's having feelings that make
sense in their context even if those
feelings are painful and then managing
those feelings well so if a kid gets
dumped and his heart is broken we expect
to see sadness we ache for him but we
don't see that as a grounds for concern
and what we want to see is how does he
manage it does he reach out to his
friends does he put on his sad playlist
to get the sad feelings out does he go
for a run or does he smoke marijuana act
like a jerk around the house get online
and give kids a hard time that's where
our concerns that takeaway for parents
is your goal as a parent is not to make
your kid always feel good it's to help
them with bad deal with bad emotions
well or difficult emotions well I guess
they're not all none there is no such
thing as a bad emotion if it's an
appropriate one if it fits the moment
absolutely and so so much of what that
looks like is just being a steady
presence you know not overreacting not
jumping into action when we can be calm
in the face of pretty intensive
adolescent emotionality what we send a
message is that you know you may be
uncomfortable but I don't think this is
unmanageable when is it time to get
professional help
there are three things we want people to
be on the lookout for so the first thing
is we expect to see Teen moods go up and
down that is expectable we don't want to
see mood go to a concerning place and
stay there
we also don't want teenagers moods to
get in the way of their lives it
shouldn't disrupt their ability to see
their friends and go to school
and the last thing we want to watch out
for is what we call costly coping this
is where kids manage in ways that have a
cost Associated so they're using
substances or they're tearing at the
fabric relationships or they're harming
themselves
a chapter that spoke to me was chapter
three seismic shift how adolescence puts
a new emotional spin on everyday life
and that's what it seems like every day
there's something and as parents
I hate to admit it but sometimes we
tiptoe around and we don't want to ask
because we feel like we're praying how
do we get our teens to open up and talk
to us about what's going on in their
everyday lives
so
to ask teenagers questions and they'll
say like fine nothing happened here's
something I have discovered it is very
common for teenagers to wait until their
parent or parents are in bed at night
getting ready to go to sleep and then
suddenly the kid shows up and as chatty
as can be
and I was like hearing this everywhere
and I felt like what is going on and
here's what I think is happening
teens are organized around autonomy they
want to become increasingly independent
and so when we're asking the questions
we're calling the shots if they wait
till we're in bed they decide if there's
going to be a conversation they decide
the topic because teens have actually
said to me at night my parents don't ask
so many questions or bring up new topics
and I'm thinking because they're trying
to go to sleep
and then if the teenager wants the
conversation over they just say okay
good night so we have to make ourselves
available on their terms and the thing
that is so important is that the most
powerful force for mental health in
adolescence is strong relationships with
caring adults so we got to meet him more
than halfway yeah the other thing that
happens with teenagers my 13 year old
will sometimes send me a text message
with some sort of like expression of
stress or difficulty and I'll take it as
a real big deal I'll try to call him
doesn't pick up the phone and it's like
he's just offloading it was what he
wanted to do he didn't actually want me
to follow up and like have a pow-wow
about it that was it uh that seems to be
a tactic as well it's very common I call
it sort of dumping the emotional garbage
right and they're like I picked up this
garbage today I don't want it you take
it you may feel lousy but I feel better
that's a working system for the teenager
at least I have to say you talk about a
Delta vacation of black teens gender
differences and parents managing their
emotions so I really really enjoy what
you've covered in here but I think it's
helpful variety even if you're not with
a teenager I have a nine-year-old but
it's all very helpful it's a great book
you've helped me tremendously with my 13
year old this will help a lot of other
people who don't have to access you
directly uh and it's just really
powerful I actually particularly love
the section on why kids hate school in
some cases we'll leave that one for
readers at home but yeah no doubt at
least said more thank you so much thank
you the emotional lives of teenagers is
on sale now if your child is in acute
distress visit 988
lifeline.org or call or text the suicide
and crisis Lifeline at 988. we will be
right back